ich befinde mich aktuell auf einer Insel
die von Einheimischen nur die
mörderinsel genannt wird das hat
folgenden Grund seit ungefähr 10 Jahren
verschwinden hier regelmäßig Leute die
dann entweder umgebracht oder gar nicht
mehr gefunden werden der berühmteste
fallstand aus 2013 als zwei Briten
ungefähr in meinem Alter je nach einer
wilden Partynacht am nächsten Morgen tot
am Strand gefunden wurden und zwar ist
die Rede von kutao aber ist das hier
wirklich so gefährlich man muss sagen
die Insel ist wirklich sehr sehr schön
und man fühlt sich eigentlich wie im
Dschungel und wenn man das alles
vergisst was hier so in den letzten
Jahren passiert ist dann ist es wirklich
einfach nur nice ich würde mal behaupten
solange man keinen Stress mit
einheimischen anfängt braucht man ja
auch absolut nichts zu befürchten haben
denn in vielen Foren im Internet ist die
Rede von der sogenannten Insel Mafia die
ist hier wohl geben soll und die die
Oberhand über die Insel hat also immer
schon aufpassen aber ich kann euch nur
empfehlen Contao wenn ihr in der Nähe
seid auf jeden Fall mal abchecken